No rules this time, just a little history.
Alexander Hamilton was many things:
aid to General George Washington, Secretary
of the Treasury, Major General of the US Army,
lover, cheater, duelist, musical phenomenon.
But few knew his immensely influential role
in American Free Press Law
just months before his fatal duel.
Today we think of Libel as defamatory falsehood.
False written statements, especially lies
but sometimes honest mistakes,
that injure a person's reputation.
And we also think of libel as a civil claim,
criminal libel prosecutions are very rare.
In 1700s England though, criminal libel cases
were common
and they covered many written statements that
harmed a person's reputation
even if they were true.
Such statements were outlawed in part because
they were seen as likely to produce duels.
Hamilton died because of his harsh statements,
albeit oral statements, about Aaron Burr.
And when said of government officials, such
defamatory statements, again even if true,
were seen as undermining the government's
authority.
'The greater the truth, the greater the libel.'
some said.
American law was based on English law,
so many Americans assumed American law would
take the same view.
In the famous colonial era 1735 John Peter
Zenger trial,
the defense had argued that truth must be
a defense in libel cases
but though the jury acquitted Zenger, such
jury decisions set no legal finding precedent.
Enter Alexander Hamilton in 1803.
Thomas Jefferson was President, Hamilton was
a prominent New York lawyer.
When Harry Croswell, an anti-Jefferson newspaper
editor,
was prosecuted in New York State Court for
libeling Jefferson
Hamilton came to Croswell's defense.
Croswell's publication had alleged that Thomas
Jefferson had payed another editor, James Callender,
to make scurrilous against Washington and
Adams.
This allegation of Croswell's injured Jefferson's
reputation, the prosecution charged,
thus making it libel without regard to whether
it was true.
And it also injured the nation, making it
so-called seditious libel.
Croswell was convicted
after the trial judge instructed the jury that truth was not a defense in libel cases.
Croswell appealed and Hamilton, representing
Croswell,
argued that truth should have been a defense.
Today that standard actually would diminish
First Amendment protection.
At least as to matters of public concern,
the court held in 1964,
prosecutors must always prove that an alleged
libel was false
regardless of whether it was said from good
motives and for justifiable ends.
But in 1803 Hamilton's position was a great
step towards broader legal protection
for criticism of government.
And Hamilton's position swept the nation.
Not at first, the New York court split 2-2
thus leaving Croswell's conviction standing.
But Justice James Kent,
who had become one of the most influential
judges and legal writers of the early 1800s,
endorsed Hamilton's view in his opinion.
In 1805 the New York Legislature enacted a
statute implementing Hamilton's view
that truth was always a defense when published
with good motives and for justifiable ends,
phrasing that Hamilton pioneered.
In the decades after that, many state constitutions
were framed precisely this way.
To this day 20 state constitutions contain
Hamilton's formula.
Hamilton and Justice Kent had become close
friends in the years before the Croswell case.
When they were in Albany for the court sitting
that included the Croswell argument,
Hamilton, Kent and a few others had dinner
together.
Over dinner Hamilton remarked that he thought
Aaron Burr was dangerous and untrustworthy.
Burr was at the time planning to run for Governor
of New York
though he ended up being beaten by Morgan
Lewis, the trial judge in Croswell's case.
Another man at the dinner reported on these
remarks
which were then referred to in an Albany newspaper.
Burr demanded that they be retracted, Hamilton
refused, Burr challenged Hamilton to a duel
and Hamilton didn't live to see his view of
the freedom of the press become part of American law.
I'm Eugene Volokh and I approve this message.